[Musique]
je sais c'est sur le bâtiment la réforme
est nécessaire car le temps où l'on
entré dans le monde du travail dans une
entreprise et l'on y rester jusqu'à la
retraite semble de plus en plus révolue
il faut donc préparer les gens à se
recycler et à valider leurs compétences
d'un métier à l'autre c'est un travail
mené en étroite relation avec le
ministère des affaires sociales je crois
qu'on est tous conscients ici que les
liens entre emploi et formation entre
travail et formation sont telles que le
sujet ne peut pas être complètement
autonome même si et je crois que c'est
ça qui est important aussi dans travail
de nicole il faut qu'on arrive à
redéfinir quand même les finalités
propre de la formation
[Musique]